she's very dressed up you not what's
going on here are you rich you must be
rich because she needed to dress up and
you did not so there's got to be a level
of monetary compensation you bring that
you're like yeah you dress up I'm
dressed up as a piggy bank that's what
I'm doing stuff right now it's a costume
party as far as I'm concerned what do
you do for a living you're young to be
retired how old are you
this guy's a rich dude you know how much
money you gotta have to retire at 49
when you retire you're like yo this is
the money I live on to like die this is
a white guy he gonna live a long life
dog by the looks of it you're not
vaccinated but other than covert nothing
for breakfast
what do you do for a living miss you
know what you do you don't need to worry
about it
you know how you do you hold on for dear
life that's what you do